hello everyone I'm here to get my
revenge against Magnus 11 he really
crushed me last game I was trying to
create something beautiful but the app
wasn't interested and unfortunately so
I'm gonna try a more subtle approach
this game and okay just gonna if it goes
with the standard ideas I'll just play
standard myself let's go queenside
castle can't be won and yeah I didn't go
for f3 g4 but I I don't mind
let's go Knight g5 yeah okay well I will
grab some of that action
okay so your call let's go h5 pawn
captures of course and now II five yeah
that's the way to do it Knight here
that's very interesting very interesting
indeed
okay I will capture I mean it's not like
I have better things to do and if I
capture he'll go h6 and I can simply
play if I go ECT I think e 6 is actually
the idea here g 6f capture see he won't
capture push f6 and now that we've
accomplished that simply capture on h7
rook captures and now probably go for
Bishop h6 how does he Halas he untangle
here he doesn't have any tricks check
said he's very tricky I have to be
careful if rook h1 I don't have a
serious follow-up so I guess
Russia page six okay
I feel you man
b3 that's how he'll do it that's how
he'll do it huh
okay I can really feel this is winning
but I know he's gonna trick me somehow I
don't even want to capture the rope I
want to play Bishop captures if King
captures Queen checks can get fate or g8
Queen h8 is checkmate
but if I capture and he ignores me I
want to finish this as soon as possible
if he captures with the rook he still
can't stop checkmate he can only stop
checkmate if he ignores me but if he
ignores me I'll simply play yeah
actually that capturing but the bishop
actually just prolongs prolongs it so
yeah he could
yeah okay this is winning what am I
thinking Bishop characteris is winning I
don't even have to I can ignore the rook
you know if I was playing against the
human I would have already done this but
engines are tricky bastards if rook
captures still Queen h6 is winning wait
if rook captures Queen h6 then even if I
check in King f8 I don't really have any
any animating ideas here
he can to go king of famine I'm seeing
ghosts capture screen h6 can get faith
Queen h8 will have to block
templayer will catch one captures
captures King g7 locate your seventh
King g6 capture probably good but funny
yeah it's it's obvious I should have
captured that rook on just down a piece
and I wrote I ruined the game I'm sure
it's still winning but why allow such a
thing that's that's just insane
okay if I threatened checkmate on f7
he'll just block rook g7 and I can't
really do anything if I play Queen at
five he'll just move the King no he
can't move the King so that's it queen
of five yeah huh such a such a nice move
but
come on do I really have to take a draw
here
rocket rate is rocket rate winning
it must be rocket a to Quincy sex
threatening checkmate if he stopped
yeah rocket jet is winning don't don't
roll me man
rocket rate perfectly winning ah ha the
weasel oh man I mean it's a useless move
but still how he prolongs it it's it's
amazing I have to give up the Queen
sorry dude yeah let's go Queen g6 yes
that will not help you sir oh yeah okay
someone told me he resigns at age 11 but
this is just okay that was one intense
game I mean I could have captured that
rook but I thought that would only
prolong the game okay one star but I
mean I'll take one star again stage 11
so yeah that's it I hope you enjoyed
this wild game and I
I mean I want to say I'll get back to
you once I defeat age 12 but I don't
know if age 12 will be will be
defeatable you know maybe maybe after
some training but we'll see so that's it
I would like to thank William Clausen
for contribution to my channel thanks a
lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I will see you soon